[Music]
foreign
Ridge on Sunday the clocks have gone
forward not that me and the team have
noticed this morning of course uh the
days are longer and it almost feels like
number 10 has a bit of a spring in its
step after a couple of recent wins
including that deal on Northern Ireland
the government is offering plenty of red
meat on solid Tory territory this
morning there's a new push on
anti-social Behavior a more tough talk
on taking on the judges over Small Boat
Crossings so lots to get teeth gnashing
on all sides and lots to discuss with
our guests this morning
in just a moment we will hear from the
leveling up secretary Michael Gove on
the program and for labor we have the
party in Shadow culture secretary Lucy
Powell with more headlines on those
small Boat Crossings we'll speak to the
UN Refugee agencies representative to
the UK that's picking tenants and with
Junior doctors going ahead with more
strikes I'll talk to the British medical
associations Dr Rob lawrenson
there'll be a new Scottish first
Minister announced tomorrow as well but
will the Scottish greens remain in
Coalition with them we'll talk to the
green co-leader lawnerts later
plus a very emotional and difficult
subject sexually motivated manslaughter
will speak to someone directly affected
Carol Gould and also the conservative MP
who has campaigned for a change in the
law Laura Faris
[Music]
I have a really busy show this morning
so let's crack straight on shall we with
the first interview just a few moments
ago we spoke to the leveling up
secretary Michael Gove
before we start on the antisocial
Behavior stuff that I know you are Keen
to talk about I just don't want to get
your reaction to the Sting the
undercover expose by the anti-brexit
group led by donkeys Matt Hancock quasi
Quan saying among other MPS saying that
they would work for a fictional company
for ten thousand pounds a day it's
within the rules does that mean we
should care about the rules no I think
it's important that uh first of all that
we make sure that every MP operates in a
way which is transparent so when members
of parliament do do work which
complements the work that we do in the
House of Commons then it's absolutely
vital that we know who's paying them
what they earn and that's what the the
register is there for I think it's also
appropriate as well the Parliamentary
standards commissioner has the
opportunity to investigate and to look
at any activity that may uh cross the
line uh on this occasion I think it's
pretty clear that things that were
offered and things that were considered
were within the rules but inevitably all
of us will reflect on this and think the
the first duty of a member of parliament
is towards their constituents and
ultimately the really important thing is
is an MP delivering for their
constituents is a member of parliament
doing everything they can to put Public
Service First
is the other issue that they didn't seem
to do much due diligence on this company
did they given that it was non-existent
well again the the individual's concern
will have to answer for themselves uh it
is the case that there are members of
parliament who do work for
um a variety of organizations that
complements what they do so for example
Maria Caulfield Health Minister also
works as a nurse down Paul to previously
a health Minister works as a doctor so
it is possible to combine additional
activity with your responsibility
towards your constituents but each
individual MP must judge for themselves
is what they're doing something that
they can defend are they making sure
it's transparent and within the rules
but above all is it the case that
they're putting their constituents first
okay now you're announcing measures to
tackle anti-social Behavior today what's
the big idea well the most important
thing here is to recognize that
antisocial Behavior can ruin lives so
crime has been reduced neighborhood
crime has down as a result of the steps
that we've taken over the course of the
last 13 years but it's still the case
that in too many areas people's lives
are blighted by the type of activity
that in particular means that town
centers become no-go areas that parks
and public spaces become despoiled to
what we're saying is we want more
visible policing in those areas that we
know are hot spots for anti-social
Behavior we want to have faster justice
so that the jobs have been responsible
for doing damage in a particular area
repair damage more quickly but also we
need to nip this problem in the bud
right at the very beginning we need to
recognize that some of the the reasons
that fuel antisocial Behavior are
essentially to do with the way in which
uh young people are sometimes it's not
either support the structure that they
need and therefore looking in particular
at making sure that there are other
activities for young people and I'm
working with the education secretary of
course to look at truancy and persistent
absence as well faster Justice yes
um so the reports say these punishments
could be turned around in 48 hours yes
there'd obviously be no trial there not
much chance to defend yourself who
actually
decides on the Justice the police and
crime commissioner because I just wonder
you know do we really trust the police
right now because it feels like this is
an elevated role for policing in the
papers today just to pick two headlines
strip Searchers of children as young as
eight shocking findings of my report
into please keep me awake said the
children's commissioner would my son
have been assaulted and held in custody
if he wasn't black Louise Casey review
of course found institutional misogyny
and racism in the police do we really
want to give them a bit more power here
well I think it's absolutely vital that
we uphold the role of the police in
maintaining Law and Order that you're
absolutely the police you're absolutely
right to say that the Casey report was
shocking uh what it revealed about the
Metropolitan Police is unforgivable
um and the commissioner Mark roley is
taking steps to deal with that but
ultimately we do have to make sure that
our police force can command confidence
but it can also be in a position to
ensure that we have order on our streets
so
um we need to do two things we need to
make sure that where the police have
either been poorly LED or have been
operating in a way that is forfeited or
risked public trust that there is
visible change but the overwhelming
majority of police officers are people
with a sense of vacation they join the
police because they want to make a
contribution to their Community they
want to uh deal with crime they want to
uphold and or delay public environment
and that's what we need to do so if you
are going to try and really get this
kind of fast Justice out yes and do you
commit to checking that it's not
disproportionately impacting people from
for example uh black backgrounds yes and
so one of the reasons why we're piloting
uh this approach in different areas
across the country is that we believe
it's absolutely right to Surge police
numbers in in these areas and to have
fast justice but the pilots are intended
to ensure that we can learn so if for
any reason there are ways of operating
that are not those which command public
confidence that we can change and you
are absolutely right as well it's
vitally important that the uh the police
operational way which is entirely free
of prejudice I should say however that
it is very often people from uh black
and minority ethnic backgrounds who are
disproportionately the victims of crime
so it is important to recognize that if
we want to have a safe Society for every
citizen in which people whatever their
background whatever their circumstance
can feel safe that we need to take
action and anti-social behavior in
particular is a problem in uh in
communities that have been overlooked
and undervalued in the past it is part
of leveling up to ensure that people can
feel that their High streets are safe is
the government planning to ban laughing
gas nitrous oxide yes um
I think any of us who've had the
opportunity to walk through our parks in
our major cities
um will have seen these little canisters
these silver canisters which are
examples of people not only displaying
public spaces but also people taking a
drug which can have a psychological
neurological effect and one that
contributes to antisocial Behavior
overall so this would be under the 1971
misuse of drugs act would be what class
A Class B Class C how did it work um I
don't know which class we would um
attribute to it but we will We want to
make sure that the uh the sailing use
can be restricted for its appropriate
purpose we can't have a situation we
mustn't have a situation where uh our
parks are public spaces become
drug-taking Arenas um and that is why we
need to do Crackdown on new
manifestations of drug taking and these
laughing gas canisters are are an
increasing Scourge and one that's been
reported to me as a constituency MP and
the advisory Council on the misuse of
drugs recommended against making illegal
and they said the current evidence
suggests that Health and Social harms of
nitrous oxide are not commensurate very
nice word there with control under the
misuse of drugs act in 1971. I mean
you've done drugs yourself you've
admitted to taking cocaine on certain
occasions are you really going to give
people a quick criminal record for
taking laughing gas well we want to make
sure that we deal with the scourge and
uh it is the case that uh we need to be
clear that there are types of activity
particularly types of activity that
cause distress to others in public which
are unacceptable and of course it's
absolutely right that we uphold the law
in this case yes the advisory committee
have offered their advice but ultimately
it's ministers who are responsible and
we believe collectively that it is
absolutely vital that
um we deal with this Scourge and in the
same way one of the things that we're
also doing is making sure that there can
be extended drug testing of people who
are responsible for criminal and
anti-social activity we need to deal
with it do you not think there is a bit
of an issue where people may look at
politicians who've taken drugs
themselves and thinking hang on it's a
bit hypocritical no I think it's because
I've learned okay what have you learned
that it's a mistake worse than a mistake
uh to uh regard drug taking is somehow
acceptable okay
um now kirst armor said a labor
government wouldn't treat cannabis as a
low-level crime he said there's a family
in my constituency where every night
cannabis is Creeps in from the street
outside into their children's bedroom
it's not low level it's ruining their
lives do you think that kind of best use
it's a low-level crime no I don't
believe it's a low-level crime I think
that it is absolutely right that people
uh see the law upheld uh and uh the uh
experience of so many uh not just with
neighbors who are behaving in an
anti-social way but in our high streets
and in our public parks is that they see
the law being floated and that's not
acceptable we do need to make sure that
um in public spaces order is maintained
and uh it's just not
to use the word they used earlier
commensurate with people feeling a
degree of pride in their Community to
see it being used as a uh you know a uh
free-for-all when it comes to Breaking
the Law
all right just to move on to
gonna be voting on the illegal migration
Bill and people who arrive in the UK and
small boats being deported including to
countries like Rwanda and now some
rebels in the conservative party are
backing an amendment that would ban
British judges from using legal
precedent from the European courts of
Human Rights is that realistic is it
something the government would consider
well the most important thing to do is
to make sure that we pass this
legislation we've got to stop the votes
and the conservative party recognizes
that the only way in which you can have
confidence in accepting new people into
this country as we have so generously
with the home for Ukraine scheme with
Afghans with British Nationals from Hong
Kong is to control our borders and I
know that the immigration Minister
Robert Generac has been working
incredibly hard to make sure this
legislation Works has been talking to
MPS who may be in a position to ensure
that every aspect of this bill Works in
my experience as a minister it's always
a good idea to talk to back benchers to
make sure that your legislation can
achieve everything that you hope it
might how do you feel personally I mean
ask this question to Oliver down as well
how do you feel personally about the
idea of children many from very
difficult backgrounds may have
legitimate Asylum claims being sent to
Rwanda I think it's absolutely right
that we uphold the law one of the things
that we're doing alongside making sure
that we stop the boat is also
establishing safe and legal routes for
Asylum keeps more safe and legal routes
should be created then because as you
and I know it's not that easy to find a
safe and legal route from most countries
in the world well it's the Home
Secretary and the Prime Minister have
made it clear but we want to establish
those routes so that we can take a
number of people should there be more
than well Parliament will decide uh how
many people we can take well my view is
that we should I I was um involved in
establishing creating and maintaining
the homes for Ukraine scheme I think we
should uh show compassion to people who
are fleeing persecution but we also need
to be clear about two things there is a
limit no country can have an infinite
number of new people arriving but it's
also the case that we need to
demonstrate that we have effective
control of our borders the people who
are exploiting the
um situation at the moment are criminal
organizations trading in human misery
um and we need to make it clear that
their business model will be broken
uh now you of course were education
secretary so I'm quite interested to get
your view on the recent scrutiny of
ofsted in the wake of the you know very
sad death of the head teacher Ruth Perry
are offsped inspections placing too much
stress on teachers uh well the first
thing is uh obviously when you're
talking about circumstances where uh a
clearly public spirited talented
um you know passionately committed
person has taken their life you have to
have respect for
uh her example in her family so it's
important not to I think
um uh you know be too political
um when we're reflecting on uh her
passing uh I do think however that
ofsted plays an absolutely vital role in
providing information about how schools
are performing well which we can learn
from and which schools are not
performing well and therefore need help
and intervention I think there's some
people who said that the four four you
get four grades right and that's too
much of a blunt instrument it should be
more nuanced than that well I I I think
that those grades are important but
there is one issue which I do think we
need to reflect on and look at which is
that if a school is found to have failed
its uh it's safeguarding criteria
then that is what is called a limiting
judgment and if a school is found
inadequate in that area that means it's
an adequate overall even if it has
strong teaching and learning and its
other areas are good as well so what is
safeguarding just explain what
safeguarding is the uh the set of rules
that govern the the well-being of
children within the school the health
and safety of the protection and so on I
do think we need to look at the uh the
way in which a limiting judgment as it's
called the technical term means that uh
a failure in one area means failure
everywhere else but
that is not a a criticism of ofsted
ofsted do a great job the Chief
Inspector Amanda Spielman is someone
absolutely committed to supporting
teachers to do better one of my worries
is that some of the people who are
attacking ofsted object to transparency
our anti-high standards and what we need
to do is to recognize that education has
improved in the last 13 years and the
role of ofsted under successive Chief
inspectors has been absolutely Central
to that now Westminster has been
gripped by Boris Johnson this week he
was giving evidence to the Privileges
committee about whether he deliberately
and or recklessly misled Parliament
because hearty gate now back in 2016 I
will never forget the moment when you
pull the plug on supporting Boris
Johnson's leadership campaign yes and
effectively torpedoed his campaign by
launching your own and I just want to
play what you said at the time so this
is back in 2016.
I so wanted that plan to work I worked
night and day for it
but I came to realize this week that for
all boris's formidable talents
he was not the right person for that
task
when you listen to Boris Johnson this
week did you think that you were right
all along no um I served as a member of
boris's cabinet during the time that he
was prime minister I think that uh as
prime minister he did a a very good job
for this country
um I think that uh the way in which he
managed to ensure that we left the
European Union and that the turmoil over
brexit at last came to a conclusion the
way in which he handled kovid and uh
oversaw the vaccine rollout the fastest
and most effective in Europe and also
the courage that he showed in standing
up to Russian aggression in Ukraine all
of that shows that uh as prime minister
uh he was someone who was operating in a
patriotic and public-spirited way and so
um I will continue to feel affection and
respect for Boris Johnson as prime
minister I asked Greg hands party
chairman this week if Boris Johnson was
a man of integrity
he didn't say he was he just said that
he was a great campaigning asset do you
think he was a man of integrity or is a
money Integrity I think the Boris is
someone who puts the country first yes
so you think he's a man of integrity yes
now there's just one last thing that I
want to ask you about uh Matt Hancock's
whatsapps oh yes because a few of the
exchanges that appeared in the Daily
Telegraph between you and Matt Hancock
were I to be completely awesome I'm not
actually sure what adjective I should
use to describe them but we can just
have a quick look at some of the
exchanges between you and the house
secretary
this is a YouTuber Hancock there lots of
emojis lots of affections why why do you
love my Hancock so much then
um but because he was doing something I
think on that particular day that I
admired he was throwing himself into the
battle against covid
um of course it's the case that there
are all sorts of critiques of how we as
a government handled covert and we need
to reflect on those but I still believe
that notwithstanding other events that
Matt was someone who in that role was
working incredibly hard to uh to deal
with the virus and its effects and I
think that um were you taking the Mickey
out of him slightly I just wonder no not
on that this is all very serious right
uh it was uh an expression of earnest
admiration at a time when he was working
incredibly hard you are right that
sometimes uh when you're sending a
WhatsApp people may not recognize that
you're saying it with a twinkle in your
eye but on this occasion I was at my of
what Matt did okay and I think the key
thing is you know uh in politics uh we
can often have uh individuals who
attract uh criticism and oblique but
uh when people were working as Matt was
so hard to try to do the right thing
then we're all part of a team that
offers support this is my favorite what
are we trying to achieve in this meeting
letting people Express their concerns in
a therapeutic environment before you and
I decide the policy quite a lot of
meetings like that
I think you could probably say that that
was uh that was written with a twinkle
in my eye and uh by tongue in my cheek
from time to time on WhatsApp I suspect
even at the sky Newsroom uh though it
will be the case that people send
messages which are intended to provoke a
rise file rather than necessarily
provoke action okay thank you very much
indeed thank you
my conversation there with Michael Gray
the leveling up secretary well let's get
the view from labor now shall we we're
joined by the shadow culture secretary
Lucy Powell good to have you on the
program uh Lucy Powell um if I may I
just want to get your reaction first to
the anti-social Behavior Crackdown that
we've seen in the papers today I mean
look parties do this thing from time to
time don't they say they're going to be
tough on crying they're going to crack
down on anti-social Behavior what's your
take on this government policy
well look we've heard it all before from
this government and I think we have to
judge them by their record and Community
sentencing over the last 13 years is
downed not just by a third but by
two-thirds over the last 13 years and
we've heard announcement after
announcement I remember Boris Johnson
saying something very similar to this
about 18 months ago Theresa May before
him saying something very similar they
scrapped the asbo regime that the last
Labor government brought in and under
their watch anti-social Behavior has got
worse sentencing has fallen immeasurably
and we're seeing crimes going unsolved
so yes we hear these sort of reboots and
another reboot and another announcement
to get the the Sunday media retention uh
but but I think it amounts to nothing
and I think people will judge this
government on their record
in some ways the biggest newsline I
thought that came out of the interview
with him on the antisocial Behavior was
the fact that the government is going to
ban nitrous oxide so laughing gas under
the 1971 misuse of drugs acts now that
does go against the advisory council's
recommendations what's Labor's position
should laughing gaspi band
I think we we want to see it see it
banned as well because I think it does
cause a huge amount of littering of
disruption uh and of anti-social uh
Behavior Uh challenges as well I did I
did see that report uh myself and
understand there are uh balancing of of
views here
um but you know we do need to tackle at
source these kind of crimes and this
kind of be held sometimes they're not
crimes but these kind of behaviors that
are blights on on our communities and
it's it's something when I go door
knocking in my constituency in
Manchester Central and I go out and
meeting residents anti-social behavior
is probably the number one issue that
they that they raise with me and they
feel that they don't have the police on
the beat that they can turn to and
that's why Labor's committed to an extra
13 000 neighborhood police officers
because we've seen those numbers
dramatically fall uh over recent years
and they don't feel that they've got the
powers and the says in the agency to get
these issues tackled in their in their
local community so we need enforcement
we need sentencing we need people to
have the powers that's local authorities
as well as police to tackle some of
these issues and we need to deal with uh
some of these challenges at source as
well so that we can prevent people from
undertaking these kind of activities
whether that's fly tipping whether that
is drug taking drug dealing whether
that's noise pollution and all of these
issues that are real Bliss on
communities we need a comprehensive plan
to do that and and labor has got that
comprehensive plan and you heard from
cased armor last week's laying out his
big vision for tackling crime and
anti-social behavior in this country and
that's why I think it's no coincidence
that the government has suddenly
alighted upon this issue today
and now I want to talk to you with your
Shadow culture secretary hassle because
you're launching an independent review
panel into the BBC one of the things
that you wanted to look into is ensuring
the BBC is independent of government do
you think the BBC is independent of
government right now
well I think there are some perception
uh challenges at least in that regard
and the reason that I've launched this
independent review panel today was some
very preeminent uh people from the
industry working with me who are going
to make recommendations and and advise
labor on the future uh direction is
because the BBC does face the number of
headwinds but we're we're sure that as
the labor party that we support a
universally funded Public Service uh
publicly funded broadcaster in this
country we think that's absolutely
critical but there are a number of
headwinds that it faces it's got a
charter renewal coming up there are
constant questions around its future
funding this government have basically
put the BBC uh under threat in terms of
its its future funding its independence
and impartiality is constantly uh being
questioned and at the center of of
culture wars and course in the in the
streaming age the platform age the
social media age that we are now living
in there are big challenges for the BBC
and that's why I want this panel at this
stage to really do some deep policy work
for labor on these issues that we can
secure the future of the BBC not just to
survive but to thrive into the Next
Generation
I'm still a little bit unclear on what
the answer to the initial question was
about the independence of the BBC could
you say that there's a perception issue
you said that the independence is being
questioned
do you think it's independent of
government you've called for the
chairman Richard to resign
well I think that there are have been
serious issues uh lately obviously there
are a number of issues around the
appointment process of the of the chair
which is now under investigation because
I asked for that investigation because
quite clearly the relationship between
uh that the chair that was appointed and
the then prime minister was was one a
lot closer and involved a lot of
financial issues that we weren't aware
of at the time the appointment of other
members of of the board of the BBC but
also this keeping I think what we've
seen from this government in particular
is is keeping the BBC at heal by
constantly threatening uh its future so
this time last year the then culture
secretary Nadine Doris said that the
license fee settlement would be the last
license fee as we know it and that
there's some in the future there would
be some other way of funding the BBC yet
they said nothing about that they were
supposed to bring in a Media bill to
cure prominence of the BBC they've not
done that there are constant threats
that hanging over the BBC and the
charter renewal coming up in the next
few years is another one which I think
is a way in which that this government
is trying to keep uh its foot on the
throat of the BBC
there's a lot of scrutiny at the BBC and
it's impartiality and Independence
what's your view on the trend of other
channels employing serving MPS as
presenters obviously we have someone
like David Lammy on LBC leanderson the
conservative Deputy chairman earning a
hundred thousand pounds presenting on GB
news
well I think it's it's very concerning I
think what is happening on uh some uh
other uh channels in terms of that
overall balance of of opinion and this
issue has been raised with the chief
executive of ofcom both by select
committee members of the of the select
committee recently and also uh it's it's
something that I've been raising uh in
private as well and ofcom should be
looking at these issues because they're
the licensing Authority they're the
regulatory Authority and I think it's
really important that in this era of
decent misinformation we need to know
that we can trust our news channels and
our news sources and it's something that
we are very proud of in this country
because we do have a a strong regulatory
regime and news channels and
broadcasters are bound by those
licensing conditions which mean that
they do have to provide balance and some
impartial quality and and I'm not sure
that that constantly ramming the
airwaves of of any one of those channels
full of sitting conservative MPS is
necessarily the right way of dealing
with that
just one quick question to finish we're
talking a bit on the program today by
MPS outside earnings and undercover
staying from the anti-brexit group led
by donkeys caught some MPS including
Matt Hancock and quasi quite offering to
work for 10 000 pounds a day within the
rules is there a problem with the rules
there is a problem with the rules and I
think no one can watch that video and
see these reports without feeling
sickened quite honestly at them parading
themselves around trying to to get extra
paid political consultancy because
that's what that is and that's why we've
been calling for an end to Second jobs
for for MPS and end to these paid
political consultancy roles being an MP
is is absolutely a full-time job it's
not just a full-time job it's a whole
lifetime uh commitment and our
constituents need us to be fully focused
on that not working out whether we've
got other interests and whether we are
pursuing other commercial ends in doing
our job so I was pretty appalled and
sickened by those uh by those
Revelations and that's why we'll be
redoubling our efforts to try and get
second jobs banned for for MPS okay
thank you very much indeed Lucy pal
there are talking to us this morning
from Manchester
busy show already we've seen different
points of view on of course the outside
earnings but a bit of a consensus when
it comes to battling the sale of
laughing gas still to come on the
program this morning we are going to be
talking to the UN hcr's representative
to the UK Vicky Tennant about that small
boats legislation and a little bit later
we'll hear from the British medical
association's Dr Rob lawrenson as well
that's about the doctor strikes plus
we'll get some reaction from our Deputy
to Sam coats who's watching all our
interviews uh there he is we can talk to
Sam a little bit later
[Music]
foreign
the government's controversial new
migration legislation makes its way
through the commons it bars people who
come here on small boats from claiming
Asylum many of them are expected to be
removed to Rwanda now the un's refugee
agency the unhcr says it breaches
international law and this morning the
Sunday Telegraph is also reporting that
the Home Secretary is looking to ban the
European Court of human rights from
blocking those flights to Rwanda well we
could talk now to the unhcr's
representative to the UK Vicky a Tennant
thank you very much for being with us
this morning so MP set to vote soon on
this legislation what's your message to
them well we're very concerned that this
sets a global precedent it effectively
distinguishes the right as you've said
to to seek asylum in the UK for all but
a very few refugees
um we know that those coming across the
channel broadly reflect the
nationalities of countries affected by
crisis by by persecution globally so
we're talking about countries like Syria
Afghanistan Eritrea Iran Iraq Albania
several of these as I've said
um countries that are producing High
numbers of of refugees so this is going
to really as as you've said it um it's
in breach of international law it's in
breach of the UK's obligations under the
international just Refugee convention
just to pick up on that you should say
it's a breach of Law and I just want to
show you the unhcr's verdict on that
legislation so you say the bill if
enacted would breach the UK's
obligations under the refugee convention
the 1954 convention relating to the
status of stateless persons the 1961
convention for the reduction of
statelessness and international human
rights law so you're pretty clear that
they are breaching international law
what happens if that does happen will
the U.N do anything
well we work with governments and our
job is to continue to engage with um
with governments and try to find
practical Solutions practical
Alternatives and we we believe there are
practical Alternatives much more
realistic Alternatives
um that that could be pursued and indeed
to some extent are being pursued by the
government so for example we think the
the focus of attention really needs to
be on the Asylum system on Asylum
process and getting that working
properly so that people are able to
present their claims if they're not
refugees decision can be made quickly
they can be returned to their own
countries and if they are refugees then
they're able to to embark on that
integration journey and we think that's
in everyone's interests not just the
refugees interest but also the interests
of the British public so if a country is
found to be in breach of international
law what happens
well it's we work there's no sanction as
as such
um but the the the impact of that is is
quite it has an impact globally you know
we have to remember that the vast
majority of refugees are hosted in
countries neighboring their own so more
than 69 70 are in countries neighboring
their own now if you're a country like
turkey hosting more than 3 million
refugees or Bangladesh hosting you know
just short of a million refugees with
all the impact that has on your economy
on your infrastructure on your services
and then you look at a country like the
UK much further away much less impacted
many fewer refugees and that sends a
really unfortunate signal so we believe
that if this goes ahead it's going to
have a really if other countries were to
follow suit it really would have a very
significant impact on Refugee protection
globally the government says that look
it's seeing more and more people making
this extremely dangerous Crossing and a
legal Crossing um on small boats for the
channel it's got to do something about
it
absolutely and as I said there are
alternatives the you know we've made
recommendations two years ago to the
government on mechanisms on systems that
allowed them to improve the the Asylum
processing clear the backlogs get people
through the system quickly which we
believe is absolutely key
um we're also it's also important the
dialogue with neighboring countries is
important these countries won't have
return agreements in place so what is
the UK supposed to do it has them with
countries like Albania but many other
countries it you know it's just not
practical to do that well we say that uh
you know the the the focus of attention
needs to be on getting people through
the system quickly and then on returning
those who are not in need of protection
to their own countries and that's the
that's really where the the focus of
effort needs to be okay the government
also expects to put forward plans to
start moving at migrants out of hotels
and into military bases maybe even just
used ferries what's your take on that
well clearly housing Asylum seekers in
in hotels indefinitely is not
um it doesn't make sense now essentially
the the key is that people are able to
live in accommodations to their needs
where their basic needs are met where
International standards are met but as
I've said the key really is not leaving
people in limbo indefinitely so not
having them sit waiting for decisions on
their Asylum claims indefinitely if you
can get that happening quickly a lot of
these problems costs related to
accommodation would would fall away but
I just wanted to point out as well that
under this under this bill if it were to
go ahead what you will have is people in
even more of an indefinite limbo so they
won't even be admitted to the Asylum
system in the in the first place
um so you know unless they can be
removed to to a third country and we
have a lot of concerns about how that is
being is being pursued but unless that
is the case and at the moment there are
no Arrangements that are operational
they're simply going to be here in limbo
indefinitely and that's not in anyone's
interest thanks very much coming in
interesting to get your take ahead of
that important legislation it's next
week now as usual the tape will follow
this program just after 9 30 but we have
a little take now from sanco's adaptive
political editor on some of the
headlines that have emerged this morning
what stood up to you so far Sam
well I think this morning Sophie looking
at your interviews with Michael gave and
Lucy Powell is just a real feeling that
politics has turned a page last week we
left behind brexit potentially for quite
some years to come
um and we've got that uh uh and we've
moved on to something new what that
looks like with the government putting
forward anti-social Behavior plans Labor
uh laying into broadcasters and uh
effectively a deep look once again at MP
second earnings it just feels like we're
heading for an election all of these
things tend to happen as a parliament
draws to a close that's exactly what
you're getting this morning with crime
and anti-social Behavior being the focus
of one party quite how it's all reported
being the focus of the other uh and MP's
earnings uh being at front and center
okay Sam thanks very much I do have lots
more uh from Sam around at 9 30 this
morning as well so lots more analysis to
come
now strikes nurses have done a deal with
government teachers are in intensive
talks over perhaps a similar deal but
talks with Junior doctors collapsed and
they will now start a new four-day
strike in a couple weeks time with the
British Medical Association says that
Duty doctors need a 35 pay rise to make
up a blow inflation Rises for many years
and the BMA Junior doctors committee
co-chair Dr Rob lawrenson joins us now
thanks very much for being good morning
one knows the important role that Junior
doctors play in the Health Service is
there strike action four days is that
going to put lives at risk I don't think
so and actually the NHS has shown itself
to be very resilient over our last
action which was last week over a 72
hour period where many uh Healthcare
professionals like consultants and
Associate Specialists were able to
provide and support care in services
like a e and intensive care there's a
lot of appointments canceled though
isn't there I mean there's already a
huge backlog anyone who's waiting for an
appointment knows that there is and
that's precisely one of the big
arguments that we're trying to put
forwards there's a massive Workforce
crisis in doctors and other Healthcare
Professionals in the NHS and I just want
to draw a comparison to a normal working
day if a consultant were to go off sick
or if they were unable to attend their
Clinic duties we'd see all of those
appointments rescheduled and they would
be rescheduled for months in advance
which demonstrates how little Workforce
capacity we have so these this strike
action yes it causes disruption and I'm
sorry for that but it just demonstrates
that we have 9 9 000 vacancies in
secondary care we have 6 000 fewer GPS
and it's very difficult for patients to
Access healthcare that they deserve
let's talk numbers you want a 35 pay
rise it's a pretty big pay rise so
doctors have lost 26.1 over the last 15
years in real terms and what we're
asking for is for that to be restored so
we're asking for it to go back to a
cost-neutral point of view from 2008 and
what that looks like is about a five to
ten pounds an hour increase at the
moment doctors start on 14 pounds an
hour and we're just asking that to that
for that to be restored to 19 pounds now
I think lots of people would be like
look Junior doctors are underpaid and
you've had as you say a whole 15 years
of squeezed but is it realistic to be
asked to click the fingers at these
times of economic difficulties and make
up for 15 years worth of below inflation
pay Rises it's not going to happen is it
so so there are some challenges that we
need to work out in the negotiation room
and so yeah
is that what you're saying so I think
there's many different ways to be able
to get to full pay restoration and I
think it's really important but when we
talk about realism or the reasonability
of it I think what what's happened is is
that Mr Barkley and ourselves are just
at different points and trying to tackle
this issue he's coming at it from
quibbling over about one billion pounds
which when you put into perspective of
the test and Trace budget yeah it's very
easy to look at the PPE business
because I understand it's it's easy to
look at the amount of money that was
spent during covert but at the time we
were in the middle of a global pandemic
people didn't know what was going on it
was right to the time some would argue
to put money into things that could try
and make a difference right now everyone
is about titling across the board we've
seen nurses making a deal we've seen
teachers uh getting around the table as
well and for many people you guys look
like an outline
so you know absolutely and this is what
I'm saying so Mr Barclay is coming at it
from complaining about one billion
pounds we're coming at it and saying
look we have a health care crisis at the
moment we have 500 excess deaths 500
British people dying needlessly a week
in Winter and we're trying to address
real Health Care crises and so we're
trying to approach this from a
perspective of doctors looking after
patients and wanting to deliver high
quality health care and Mr Barclay is
just trying to pinch pennies
except Pinch A petting and penny
pinching a 35 pay rise I think if you
were to ask the ordinary person on the
street would they be happy to pay a
doctor 7 P.M on a Friday night 19 pounds
an hour I think you'd get a resounding
yes that's reasonable we're streeting
the man who could be Health secretary in
18 months time at Labor's Shadow said
this on Friday on LBC I don't support
the strike actually I don't want the
strikes to go ahead what's your message
to labor uh well I would be happy to
work with anyone who is in power to be
able to deliver full pay restoration for
doctors again you know this is about
trying to address serious Workforce
crisis that that are putting each and
every one of us at risk every winter
Mr streetings made some comments about
not supporting strike but he did make a
comment about understanding the argument
for full pay restoration and I think
that's the difference that we have
um between Mr streeting and Mr Barkley
Mr Barkley doesn't even recognize the
stresses and the pressures that Junior
doctors are under and that's why we're
so far apart why are you not getting
around the table oh no we're very happy
to get around the table so next week
will Mark six months since we started
our formal trade dispute and Mr
Barkley's only come to the table twice
it's really very difficult to be able to
talk to someone who doesn't even want to
invite us in and indeed on Wednesday he
left the room
what happened
he asked us uh um you know what we would
like to talk about we presented our
opening position on what we think would
constitute full pay restoration and how
we'd like to work with him but he didn't
ask us any further questions he didn't
ask us how to hi do you think you've got
into your heart so I think one billion
pounds for 75 000 Junior adopters to be
able to try and treat the massive
Workforce crisis and to be able to
deliver high quality care to the people
of this country I think that's value for
money okay thank you very much for
coming on the program it's good to have
you here explaining your position thank
you much appreciated
well lots of different things on the
program today and I'm really looking
forward to maybe looking forward to the
wrong word but I'm very pleased to
introduce our next subject because this
week the Justice secretary Dominic Robb
announced tougher sentences for
perpetrators of domestic homicide and
sexually motivated manslaughter well a
woman is now killed every three days in
the UK and we are joined now by the
concept of MP Laura Faris and Carol
Gould who is the mother of murdered
teenager Ellie Gould to discuss whether
enough has been done to tackle violence
against women first of all thank you so
much for coming in obviously Laura it's
lovely to have you here but I'm really
very happy and you know humbled really
that you've taken the time out to come
and talk to us on what I know must be a
really difficult subject for you so we
really appreciate that thank you okay
thanks for having me it's important
things to discuss yeah absolutely right
um Laura do you want to just talk us
through your campaign and what's
happening now yeah well thank you again
for um
showing an interest in this issue
this is the second part really of the
campaign we got the prohibition on the
so-called rough sex defense where it
said that the victim consented to fatal
injury in The Domestic Abuse Act and one
of the things that campaigners and MPS
felt at the time is that that was being
used as a defense often to avoid a
charge of murder and to get manslaughter
and often actually having it framed by
the court as an unfortunate accident
that was regrettable and probably partly
her fault too we got it into the
Domestic Abuse Act which made it a more
serious offense it was much more likely
than to be charged as unlawful at
manslaughter rather than gross
negligence manslaughter but there was
still a string of cases where people
were getting to rise of resentences less
than you could get for pet theft less
even actually a one or two cases the
sampaibus case being an example then the
maximum you could get for non-fatal
strangulation when he fatally strangled
his victim so I have been I had a
private members Bill actually and I've
been hammering on the door of the MOJ to
look again at sentencing on this and to
create a new starting point that puts it
into a higher sentencing bracket and
that's the effect of the announcement
this week that it that it is likely or
the the invitation will firstly be
extended to the sentencing Council but
there is a right to put for the MOJ to
legislate if they don't that the new
starting point will be eight to twelve
years so so double figures uh as a
minimum and I think that you know must
fairly reflect the gravity of the crime
and frankly you know the depravity of
what's happened to the woman who has no
opportunity to give her side of of the
case I mean when you say that the
minimum sentence and eight to ten years
it feels like you know it's
extraordinary that's not happening
already and hasn't happened already and
pet theft and potentially getting more
um breathtaking really
um Carol you've been campaigning
obviously
um since the death of your daughter can
you just tell us a little bit about what
happened to her if whatever you're
comfortable with sharing obviously okay
so Ellie was in the sixth form she was
17 years old and halfway through her
a-levels
um she started dating a fellow student
who's also in the sixth form
um it was a three-month relationship it
was her first boyfriend
um two months into the relationship he
then became controlling and she
described to her friends that he was
suffocating
um so she decided to end the
relationship she ended it on a Thursday
evening and she told me that she was
going to do that and on the Friday
morning while she was at home revising
he came to our house
um he strangled her and then he picked
up a knife and he stabbed her 13 times
in the neck
if that wasn't bad enough he then
focused completely on himself he washed
his DNA off of the handle of the knife
he then put her hand in the knife into
her hand and reinserted it into her neck
to make it look like suicide and then he
just walked out of our house as though
nothing had happened
completely focused on himself covering
up his tracks and then my husband came
home in the afternoon and found his
beloved daughter in a pool of blood on
our kitchen floor it's horrendous and
the sentence for that
12 and a half years 12 and a half years
for the brutal murder of our
house precious daughter
that is the justice system when it comes
to violence against women and girls
well number one he was sentenced as a
child as a 10 year old despite being
five years of his five months off his
18th birthday and secondly because
murders in the home are seen as a lesser
crime it doesn't matter how violent they
are they're diminished and um as a
result of this Claire Wade review we're
hoping to push through some much tougher
sentencing and what I would be saying to
the government now and Dominic Rob is
you've not quite cut it yet just
offering aggravating factors for
Overkill and for
um and for Creative control and behavior
is not going to level up the sentence in
what we want and we will be asking
minister arga to consult on is a 25 year
starting point for Overkill and for
strangulation because we have to
remember that this is very much gendered
violence and it's just not being
recognized in the courts how dangerous
these perpetrators are can you just
explain what Overkill is what is
overkill well it's the excessive use of
force in a homicide so you may have
strangled the person but then you use a
weapon to do much more than necessary
yes and that's a in domestic homicide
that's present in 60 of cases I think
what you say about gendered killing and
killings domestic which the phrase
itself domestic feels like a completely
the wrong word to use in these sense as
well I think that Rings true with a lot
of people including myself
um
do you think that steps have been taken
to to recognize the I guess the
injustices in the system
well as a result of the clay Wade review
now domestic homicides have been put in
the spotlight and thanks to her review
is now highlighting particular
characteristics of these murders and how
violent they are how frenzied they are
um and as I say what a public risk these
perpetrators are to society
um but her recommendations don't go far
enough so we do have a meeting hopefully
with Minister arga after Easter and we
hope to discuss
um these things further with him and
push these starting points to 25 years I
mean I don't like to compare cases but
if you think of a high profile case of
Savina Nessa horrific murder and that
perpetrator received a sentence of 36
years if you compare that to a domestic
setting the same amount of violence the
same amount of suffering to the vet in
the same danger that these people pose
and in the case of poppy the lady the
daughter of the lady that I campaign
with he his his sentence was 16 years
that's a 20-year difference how is that
how is that just because one took place
in a park and one took place in the home
what's your sort of take on this about
the gendered nature of it yeah well I
think it's really important that the
government commissioned this review
because when you read it you realize
it's the first time that that specific
domestic context has been really looked
at and made an entire framework for a
potentially new sentencing uh regime and
one of the things I think that she
really draws on is firstly the absolute
breach of trust that often is inherent
to these cases sometimes happening for
example when the victim is asleep
um also the presence of coercive control
or some form of domestic abuse as a
precursor to the total offense before
the behavior before and just also the
existence in court of outdated language
like battered women's syndrome which is
sort of an old-fashioned word for what
we would Now understand is various forms
of more nuanced domestic abuse like
coercive control or economic control or
other things that have happened and I
just think it allows for a new framework
where we recognize
the vulnerability that some women have
after a long period but she is also I
have to say Claire Wade was also Sally
challenge Barrister and so she is also
very sensitive to the women who will
perhaps after a long history of domestic
abuse retaliate and Sally challenge was
um and her sons have done some amazing
campaigns as well right and she suffered
domestic abuse for many years and then
went on to kill her so she's trying to
create a new sentencing framework that
will factor in the various impulses that
is fair to both sexes but recognizes the
pre-existing feature of domestic abuse
in the way that it can either aggravate
or mitigate depending on how the crime
unfolds I just wonder if you want to
take the opportunity to reflect a little
bit on your daughter at all and Ellie
and the kind of girl that she was and
the kind of achievements that she had I
totally understand if you prefer not to
but this is always the hard bit of any
interview but um yeah and it was
delightful she was delightful she was
really kind and caring very thoughtful
to her observers her friends often
described her as the glue amongst
different friendship groups because she
never liked anybody to be left out of
anything and she had a huge laugh at
animals
um in the you know when she was young we
always visited Farms to hold baby Lamb's
chicks and then her passion went on to
horses and she became a very you know an
excellent equestrian
um Rider and you know that that was her
passion at the weekends riding her Pony
and competing and
yeah and she has such a bright future
ahead of her you know she was looking at
joining the police force and she would
have given so much to society and you
know it's just such a Devastation that
she's been taken from us it sounds like
the kind of person that would have been
great in the police definitely she would
have done she was very balanced very
balanced she'd even completed a piece of
work as part of her a-level studies
ironically on should child murderers be
punished and she received the results
from that three days before her own
murder it's it's really quite chilling
um thank you thank you so much for
coming on the program
um you speak unbelievably eloquently the
most difficult of circumstances and you
know you should feel that you're really
making an enormous amount of change here
well I feel like we were on the first
rung of the ladder we still got a big
climb to go yet but I hope the
conservative government are listening to
us because we are really not going
to be honest thing because that their
initial response was interim they've
accepted a number of Claire ways
recommendations and there's going to be
further consultation on this so it's a
start it's a positive style voice is of
course really important we have been
promised to be part of the consultation
process so we will hold them to that I'm
sure you will I don't have any doubt on
that whatsoever and thank you both so
much for coming on the program it's like
a real pleasure and a privilege for me
to be able to talk about
thank you thank you
um really important issue and something
that we will definitely keep track on of
this program to find out how that
continues to progress
now tomorrow there will be a new SNP
leader and a new first Minister for
Scotland as well as either Hamza Youssef
Kate Forbes or Ash Regan takes over from
Nicholas sturgeon now the s p is
currently in coalition government with
the greens but would they continue to
work with a new leader well the party's
co-leader Lorna Slater joins us now
she's live in Edinburgh for us um thank
you very much for being with us and we
are of course awaiting at the new uh
leadership of the SNP what are you
hoping for tomorrow
I mean what I'm hoping is that the
Scottish greens and the Scottish
government can continue to work together
I think that's been a really productive
relationship I think Scotland Scotland
is better for it our environments better
for it bringing those sort of
progressive values concrete things that
make people's lives better our unique
Scottish child payment free bus travel
for everyone 21 and under things like
our nature restoration fund working to
tackle the biodiversity and climate
crisis in Scotland I really hope that
we'll be able to continue working
together and to deliver on these
excellent policies
you see the key question I guess is on
power sharing right because you
currently have a power sharing agreement
with the SMP in Scotland and your
co-leader has said that that could come
to an end depending on the policies that
the new leader adopts what are your red
lines there
the Scottish Queens joined the Scottish
government on the basis of an agreement
called the Butte house agreement and
that is for 50 pages of policy you can
see it online and within there is things
like commitment to gender recognition
reform commitment to tackling the
climate crisis commitment to creating
highly protected Marine areas for
example and we consider that a package
of measures the green serving government
on the basis of that agreement so any
new leader of the SNP must be committed
to that agreement as a whole for us to
be able to continue to work together
one of the key dividing lines obviously
is the gender recognition bill it is
supported by some but not all of the
contenders is that a red line for you if
they pull out of that legislation will
you refuse to enter power sharing with
them
gender recognition reform has been
passed by the Hollywood Parliament
um it was supported by members of every
party it was passed by an overwhelming
majority so that's done it's passed in
Scotland where it sits now is that the
UK government have used an unprecedented
mechanism called a section 35 to block
something that has been passed by the
Scottish Parliament so this isn't just a
matter of Human Rights this is also a
matter of protecting Scotland's
Devolution and I cannot imagine any
leader of a party that is pro-scottish
independent accepting the UK government
undermining Scottish democracy in this
way so absolutely I would expect any
leader of any pro-independence party and
in fact anyone who believes in Scottish
Devolution to challenge that
unprecedented and I think undemocratic
use of that section 35 order
I mean the s p could govern without you
as a minority Administration is it
better to keep the seat your seat at the
table
that is for the members of the I guess
SMP to decide and then for the members
of the Scottish greens to decide that
cooperation agreement I think is
committed to Progressive values it's
committed to tackling that climate and
nature crisis it is committed to a
vision of Scotland that is greener and
fairer and I very much hope that we can
continue to work together to deliver
that Vision because I think it's the
right way forward for the Scottish
people but we shall see what develops
over the next couple of days
here very much uh indeed good to have
you on the program today talking about
the road ahead uh for Scotland
well it's been an absolutely packed uh
show uh today hasn't it we've had all
sorts of things on the program from
laughing gas to that really uh powerful
uh discussion that I'm gonna remember
for an awfully long time about
um murders of women in the domestic
environment the wig ahead though is
going to be just as busy with that
illegal migration legislation facing
scrutiny in House of Commons and the
government's big push on anti-social
Behavior so now we have a moment in the
show we can take a bit of a look ahead
try and make sense of it all we're
joined by two former MPS a former labor
MP Heidi Alexander now hoping to return
to Parliament and the full former
conservative Minister Alistair Burt
lovely to have you both on the program
today I always think it's quite
interesting to talk to people who are
slightly removed from the day-to-day in
Westminster and you know can kind of
kick back and and talk a little bit more
freely hopefully about um some of the
issues on the table and I don't know if
there's anything in particular that you
guys are Keen to sort of pick out but
obviously the migration Bill are coming
up in the House of Commons feels like
it's going to be a really big one
Aleister I'm interested to get your sort
of thoughts on that
um I thought the UN HCR representative
put it very well and the issue here is
that this is a this is a problem for so
many different areas and it is a problem
because if people are forced to move
it's a problem for them and their
families and she's right that people
tend to come from conflict areas and
they go to the nearest available place
there are three and a half million in
Turkey for example we see very much the
tip of the iceberg in terms of Crossings
across the Channel having said that
it's going to continue and increase
because there is an exponential number
of people the UN itself calculates there
are 100 million refugees currently on
the Move in the world the United Kingdom
remains very attractive this isn't
something I think that can be solved by
one state alone it does have to be done
collectively how would you vote if
you're still in the comments oh I don't
know one I you know one of the joys of
not being an MP anymore
you can also admit more more honestly
you don't know the answer to everything
and you don't know what's going to work
um has has there to be something that
makes it impossible for people across
the channel and take the risks that they
do and land in Ken yes I think there has
that has to be done in cooperation with
the French and that has to be done in
cooperation with others on the migration
routes when I was Minister for in in the
foreign office we worked on those routes
we spoke to people who were making the
journey to try and persuade them don't
be with the traffickers this if you've
left for a particular reason these are
the things that can help you but it is
monumentally difficult and climate
change is going to make this worse
because more people are going to be on
the move and I'm not sure the world has
really worked out how this is all going
to be dealt with it's really it's it's
true isn't it actually and that these
are huge issues that everyone is kind of
grappling with including the labor party
as well and
you can see the obvious difficulties
with what the conservatives are
proposing but I guess also when you talk
to labor more enforcement trying to
smash the gangs I mean that's difficult
to do as well isn't it yeah I mean I
think we've got the worst of all Worlds
at the moment haven't we because you
know people who are genuine Asylum
Seekers who are fleeing Civil Wars
famine
um climate change disasters they're not
being given the opportunity to rebuild a
new life it's taking ages to process
Asylum applications a big increase in
the number of Asylum applications that
are waiting to be processed under this
government but equally we're not
removing people who don't have genuine
Asylum claims quickly enough so yes I
think we do have to Crackdown on those
gangs that are smuggling people into the
country and the labor party is put
forward some proposals about using the
money that the government have set aside
for the Rwanda scheme and setting up a
new unit within the National Crime
agency to work with other European
countries and and europol but we are
going to have to do more to speed up the
processing of applications and also
probably reform the the sort of safe and
legal routes by which people are coming
here you don't put your children in a
boat to cross the channel unless you're
utterly desperate
um and so you know I think that yeah
that's something that we have to keep at
the back of our minds as well and when
we're talking about refugees and Asylum
Seekers I think the the fundamental
principle is that I would like our
country to treat other people as we
would like to be treated ourselves if we
found ourselves fleeing a war-torn
country it's
issues where there is a clear diversion
line between conservatives and labor
another issue that we talked about on
the program where there wasn't such a
clear divide was on the Banning of
laughing gas of nitrous oxide both Lucy
Powell and Michael Gove very clear
saying that they wanted to ban that to
make it illegal
I just wonder it's interesting you're
talking there about you know issues that
you know you have different Shades of
Gray on which you can be a bit more open
about if you're not in politics and it
feels to me like drugs policy is is one
of them because the guys who are
supposed to look into these things at
the council for the misuse of drugs so
that actually you know what it's
probably not worth Banning laughing gas
but then from a political perspective
it's something that I guess
perhaps there's political capital and
seeming tough on what you say
if you're in a position of of making a a
decision then you've got to have an
answer yes or no and I I think one of
the problems of politics today it seems
to me is so many issues are becoming
much more polarized and it's become more
difficult for colleagues to to talk
roundly about something and also not
respond in a very knee-jerk fashion it
is someone who is getting high on
nitrous oxide is is that a good thing
the short answer is no of course it's
not so should it be stopped yes but how
would you do it and that is much more
complex in a society where people have
addictions to all sorts of things I've
just I I had a week in the states very
recently uh seeing the UN and seeing
State Department on on Middle East
issues and because cannabis has been
deregulated for example it's everywhere
and you can spell it as you walk down
main streets in Washington and New York
and things like that because the tourist
attraction sometimes right where people
go there specifically will that deal
with the problem by legalizing it no
problem we won't so some of these things
are are extremely difficult I've no
particular view on nitrous oxide I've
not come across it I know that the small
canisters are used by cyclists because
they're part of the part as well right
to get your tires blown up so what's
your what's yours so my reflection on
all of this listening to that debate
earlier is that you know I spend hours
every week knocking on doors in Swindon
at the moment and not one person has
raised with me the issues of nitrous
oxide
um or those small little canisters that
are pretty ubiquitous across a lot of
communities at the moment what people
have raised with me on the doorstep is
rising levels of knife crime in a town
like Swindon where you know I think a
lot of people would think that someone
like Swindon is a a safe place to live
um and actually I was really surprised
having been a member of parliament in
southeast London which had a big problem
with serious youth violence and knife
crime to find similar things things
playing out on the streets in Swindon
and so if you were asking me about what
the priority of people would be for
Action from this government I wouldn't
have necessarily said it was that I
think you're getting back to proper
neighborhood policing
um getting enough police officers on the
streets and investing in prevention so
young people aren't getting drawn into
crime is something that the public
really want to see
um we're nearly out of time but I just
want to get
I mean you're probably you're about to
go back into it so I'm not sure this is
the best question for you but what's the
thing you've enjoyed the most
after leaving Parliament what was the
thing that you've
enjoyed the most about weekends don't
tell this to me we can't because either
you had engagements in the diary uh and
of course you you worked through through
your weekends or if you didn't you
worried why didn't you have any
engagements and you worried in case you
were missing something and yeah
but the the ability to think more
broadly about things I do keep in touch
I think the abuse that MPS have suffered
is greater than it was my wife still
works in Parliament the abuse that women
suffer in Parliament is much greater
than it was the polarizing of politics
worries me a great deal so I don't miss
that I miss not being involved in
legislation and where things are going
um but I'm also a pro-chancellor i chair
the council at Lancaster University and
being involved with something different
is very good yeah and for me it's quite
interesting because I went off and
worked with the mayor of London for yeah
and a half years and so I was still very
much in political and an intense
political job even though I was
politically restricted at that time I do
agree with Alistair that um not doing
advice surgeries on a Friday evening
um when you're often there until eight
o'clock at night that was um it was nice
to have a little bit of a break from
that but I dare say that if I'm
re-elected I'll be back doing that yeah
I've made the most Friday nights now I
still care exactly thanks very much
indeed quite two as feature yesterday
well that is it for this week's at safe
Ridge on Sunday but in a moment after
break we'll run through today's
interviews uh with adaptive together Sam
coach thanks for joining us this Sunday
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the take a chance to look back at some
of our interviews this morning on the
program try and work out what we learned
what it means for the week ahead it's
been one of those weeks where it's been
unusually busy because there's been
quite a few different issues that we
were Keen to talk about on the program
today whether it's the government's ban
on nitrous oxide laughing gas that
Michael Gove confirmed the immigration
and the Asylum legislation coming up uh
next week but I'm also really glad that
we made time for that powerful interview
on the domestic homicide and the
sentencing for sexually motivated murder
with Carol Gould and Laura fallacy
conservative it was such a moving
interview I thought that I'm really glad
that we did make time for today let's uh
take a moment though and take a step
back because we can now talk through
some of the bigger political issues and
some of the big political issues with
Sam Coates our Deputy political editor
who joins us as usual on the show today
and Sam I thought you might be
interested in the led by keys at
research this is the undercover sting by
the Pro brexit Group who found out
slightly embarrassingly for the people
involved at Hancock and quasi quarantine
plus others prepared to work for ten
thousand pounds a day it challenge for
some of the work that you guys have been
doing on Westminster accounts
that's right I mean look there's an
awful lot of stuff around the government
would be much rather that we were
talking about their anti-social Behavior
stuff worth saying that through all the
headlines that you're about to read over
the next 48 hours about offenders in
high Vis jackets and immediate Justice
this is just Pilots we don't know what's
going to happen for good however in
Westminster I think there's a lot of
focus today once again on MPS and their
outside earnings because as you say uh
this campaign group now it's a sort of
left-leaning anti-brexit campaign group
called led by donkeys and they've been
doing some work with a journalist called
Anthony Barnett and they've been
effectively uh doing interviews with MPS
uh pretending that they've set up a
South Korean firm doing interviews with
MPS and asking how much they would like
to be paid if they were to work for that
company and this feeds into a
conversation we've been having on Sky
News as part of the Westminster account
it's about MPS outside earnings and I
think that we've got a little bit of
this video that we can show you that
just so you can see I think it's
important to see the nature of the
conversation which was recorded without
the permission of the MPS concerned to
get a flavor of uh of the kind of
background of why we're asking these
questions today
do you have a daily rate
at the moment I do I do yes it's 10 000
Sterling all the rates
Maybe
I mean do you have any number in mind
that we were thinking
um
anything less than for about ten
thousand dollars a month
dollars or pounds what pounds sterling
Sam you know watching the footages it's
embarrassing not least because they
haven't done much due diligence on the
company because the company didn't
actually exist
but they're not doing anything wrong are
they right
uh absolutely not even though the rules
have been tightered in December to
preclude some kind of consultancy uh
performed by MPS nevertheless I think
that uh a lot of people I'm just judging
by my kind of WhatsApp inbox a lot of
people
um are exercised or interested uh by
this
um and I think that it raises um despite
being within the rules uh a couple of
issues the first is the scale of the
earnings that we're talking about
because
um what you will have seen there is a
discussion about figures uh sums of
money and Matt Hancock talking about his
uh daily rate now I think we can bring
up uh just a a a graphic that gives you
a bit of context and this is a list uh I
think of uh the amount of money made in
2023 alone in the first couple of months
of 2023 so bear in mind that Matt
Hancock was talking about daily uh rate
of ten thousand pounds now you can see
that in the whole of 2020 three there
are only what half a dozen MPS that make
anything that have made anything like
that over the first two months of this
year and of course one of them is Matt
Hancock he registered his fee for I'm a
celebrity get get me out of here uh uh
and that's why he's got 378 000 take it
back to one of the more expensive MPS
out there Boris Johnson tops the league
table at 3.7 uh million and then you can
see uh a number of them but but you can
see I think the point I'm trying to make
by showing you this Liz you can see that
uh uh ten thousand pounds is a lot of
money for outside earnings for an MP and
even uh though this is the leaderboard
for what the top kind of 30 35 uh
actually have received on top of their
85 000 pound salary uh the color sums
that quasi quality and Matt Hancock seem
to be talking about uh would Elevate
them right to the to to the top end and
I think the other thing that that it
suggests is just as you say Sophie a
lack of due diligence um this is a
campaign group that was able to set up a
website uh and pretty quickly set up
interviews it would appear uh with MPS
who didn't really check who they were
talking to and quickly got into uh
discussions that were being recorded for
broadcast without their knowledge
um and uh and and I think that uh just
not checking is uh is something that
people might be surprised about now it's
important to put the side of MPS the MPS
uh all the MPS who are interviewed say
that they did nothing wrong I just
before we uh get to the response of
government ministers and and opposition
figures uh I just want to zero in uh
because I always want to zero in on Matt
Hancock I want to zero in uh on him uh
because uh perhaps he's going to be the
most prominent he's the most prominent
uh lead featuring person in this now uh
he's released a statement uh which said
that uh Matt Hancock acted entirely
properly uh and uh within the rules and
it's untreated suggest wrongdoing uh and
uh the video shows that Matt is uh is
acting uh properly but what's
interesting is that alongside Matt
Hancock's uh public statement uh he's
pers his press officer is a release of
lengthy background statement which I'm
not allowed to read you directly but I'm
going to convey to you the meaning of
what of how Matt Hancock feels about
what we've seen this morning because
that in itself is is quite interesting
because how Matt Hancock feels is
somewhat different and and and he's
quite upset uh and and this background
note makes it clear that the footage uh
was in uh he feels that the footage was
obtained through entrapment uh and uh
even though it shows that Matt Hancock
acted with Integrity uh they feel that
it doesn't expose the kind of level that
you would need to go to to secretly
record something which he thinks is uh
representing serious impropriety uh or
to prevent the public from being misled
um and effective he uh Matt Hancock goes
on to uh to believe that he is the
victim here because he is the victim of
somebody that has breached or an
organization that has breached gdpr
rules no those are the rules around data
release so
thing for a by Matt Hancock that uh it's
like he is the one that has been wronged
by being secretly recorded because this
breaches his privacy it'll be for
viewers at home to work out who they
side with on this issue interesting and
to hear the defense certainly
um let's talk to you let's all let's
hear a little bit from Michael guy
because I did ask him about this story
as well he obviously made the point that
there was no indication that MPS have
broken the rules although he did have a
semi-swipe should we say by saying that
it's important and piece to focus on the
constituents
it's important that first of all that we
make sure that every MP operates in a
way which is transparent so when members
of parliament do do work which
complements the work that we do in the
house of cons then it's absolutely vital
that we know who's paying them what they
earn and that's what the the register is
there for I think it's also appropriate
as well the Parliamentary standards
commissioner has the opportunity to
investigate and to look at any activity
that may uh cross the line on this
occasion I think it's pretty clear that
things that were offered and things that
were considered were within the rules
so that was Michael grave talking about
the story that wasn't on the government
grid for this Sunday morning he also
spoke to us about the story that was and
this is the anti-social Behavior Story
the government's plans to try and
introduce faster Justice for people who
have low level crime I guess he also
confirmed on this program that they will
be banning laughing gas let's have a
listen
so one of the reasons why we're piloting
uh this approach in different areas
across the country is that we believe
it's absolutely right to Surge police
numbers in in these areas and to have
fast justice but the pilots are intended
to ensure that we can learn and you are
absolutely right as well it's vitally
important that the uh the police
operational way which is entirely free
of prejudice uh I should say however
that it is very often people from uh
black and minority ethnic backgrounds
who are disproportionately the victims
of crime anti-social behavior in
particular is a problem in uh in
communities that have been overlooked
and undervalued in the past it is part
of leveling up is the government
planning to ban laughing gas yes
um uh I think any of us who've had the
opportunity to walk through our parks in
our major cities
um will have seen these little canisters
these silver canisters which are
examples of people not only displaying
public spaces but also people taking a
drug which can have a psychological
neurological effect
bring Sam back in at shall we
um it feels a little bit like we've
heard this kind of thing before a
countdown on antisocial behavior from
pretty much every prime minister I can
remember do you think this will be any
different
so as I was sort of saying a moment ago
I think that the the fine print of this
announcement is important yes it's a a
an aggressively there's an aggressively
written press release about offenders
having to wear high visibility jackets
being marched back to the scene of
crimes in order to clean up the damage
that they've been done uh if there's for
instance a graffiti
um but this is just a set of Pilots the
pilots start in June I think the
government wants you to focus on splashy
headlines I I do wonder how the
implementation of this policy is going
to go uh when it's rolled out in a
couple of months uh to certain parts of
the country you do have a couple of
questions uh the first is around the
role of who decides so you were rightly
picking up I thought Sophie on the idea
that the police will if effectively
introduce a form of summary Justice
through this scheme at a point where
trust in the police is exceptionally no
low you have the Louise Casey report
into the Metropolitan Police last week
you've got all sorts of questions about
whether or not police officers are
acting immediately are basically can be
trusted to do what they do Michael Gove
strongly defending uh the police but
there's another story uh all over the
Sunday Times about how private
contractors zeroed in on the some some
of a former Theresa May aide and the
police came along and arrested him on
the basis of what may be disputed uh
evidence uh a minor who was effectively
jumped on by private contractors and
then the police only listened to their
side of the story so there is a question
about the way that police sometimes use
the powers that they've been given to
them so for all of the headlines stop
weight and see what the outcome of these
Pilots are to me the most interesting
question today is whether or not the
government will commit to releasing the
data of how those Pilots goes because
they just want to going to want to claim
that this is going to be rolled out
before the election uh all across the
country that will only happen if these
Pilots are successful but would they
tell us if they're not which is why I
was trying to ask him a little bit about
whether we would get information about
how it was being implemented
particularly in certain communities who
have faced let's be frank discrimination
by the police previously
it felt to me like one of the biggest
news lines really on the interstitial
Behavior was the commitment to ban
laughing gas to ban nitrous oxide and I
did think it was right to ask my forgive
about his own previous drug use he has
admitted to taking cocaine himself on
several occasions you know you can't
help thinking that you know if you
remember the public and you know that
some high-profile politicians have said
that they've used drugs themselves and
now they're talking about criminalizing
laughing gas if there is a charge of
hypocrisy there
uh yes and I think that uh Michael Gove
in in effect said that he learned
lessons uh from it I Michael Gove never
uh facing any legal proceedings over uh
his admission uh that uh he took uh
drugs uh uh quite a quite a large number
of uh years uh ago but uh always happy
to answer questions on that uh in
context such as this I think the
decision over nitrous oxide is a
interesting one bit called independent
advisors have actually not recommended
going as far as the government wants uh
to do now people will have seen those
little silver nitrous oxide gas
canisters littered all over Parts as
Michael gave said
um but I think that the concern of the
independent advisors was that it's one
thing to try and stop the flow of these
canisters getting into the hands of
youngsters and being used but it's quite
another to basically hand out criminal
records that could block the lives of
people who are caught with them and
that's the path that the government is
going down so quite a Draconian
punishment for people who take uh take
this what will be classified as a drug
that could result in a in a criminal
record which Cycles back to the question
that you're asking Michael Gove whether
or not there isn't some kind of
disparity between the way different
people have been treated by the criminal
justice system over uh over over drug
use but of course labor very keen to see
be seen as tough on uh crime trough on
drug use not keen for a gap between the
two parties uh to open up which is why
uh they too say that they want to uh to
ban this practice thanks very much Sam
always great to get your take here on
the take
um we'll speak to you soon and that's it
from Sophie Ridge on Sunday this week
thanks for joining us
[Music]
thank you